hundreds of thousands of people in the
Northeast are starting the day without
electricity after deadly storms slammed
the region last night rain hail and
possible tornadoes caused heavy damage
and killed at least five people those
storms battered major cities right
around the evening rush hour causing big
havoc for workers trying to get home it
was a mess
there were a series of rescues in
Maryland overnight because of flash
flooding and the region faces the threat
of more rain today that could cause new
flooding Don Dahler is following the
aftermath of the storms in Cheshire
Connecticut Don good morning good
morning you can already hear the
crescendo of chainsaws in the distance
this tree behind me probably stood for a
hundred years but it was no match for
last night's storm the high winds blew
it over and it sliced into this
two-story house one town here in
Connecticut was getting so many 911
calls at one point that they had to
actually transfer them to their
neighboring town for response did you
see his windshield powerful winds and
baseball sized hail
prompted several counties in New York to
declare states of emergency absolutely
few pure whiteout that's bigger than a
golf ball from Maryland to Massachusetts
the storm took down hundreds of trees
and power lines leaving roads and
highways impassable this fire from a
downed line in New York got dangerously
close to homes in a car people sheltered
inside still faced threats large trees
crashed through homes in Newburgh New
York an 11 year old girl was killed when
a tree crushed the car she was in just
outside of her home thousands of
stranded commuters crowded New York's
Grand Central Terminal
after trains were suspended because of
debris from the storm what happened this
evening which couldn't have happened at
a worse time at the very very beginning
of rush hour as day turns to night the
National Weather Service issued a flash
flood emergency water rushed over roads
in Frederick County Maryland where first
responders prepared for water rescues
following up to six inches
of rain we have trees down trees into
houses people trapped between trees on
the roads trees on cars everything you
could think of
we had it clean up in parts of
Connecticut is expected to take days
maybe even longer for houses like this
and unfortunately the forecast is
calling for more rain throughout the
week
Gail Wow Don feel bad for the people
that live in that house but that really
tells quite a story I was on the train
through Connecticut yeah back from from
a shoot it was full-on ghostbusters
ghostbusters weather I mean it was grim
couldn't have happened at the worst
possible time thank you again Don Dahler